- I bless our new leader,
Catherine the Great.
[dramatic string music]
- You're calling yourself
"the Great"?
- Of course.
- Seems arrogant.
- It is if you're not great.
If you are,
they're just calling things
what they are.
- Right.
- Shh.
- Darling girl, there is
a rumor sweeping Europe
that you have taken Russia
from your husband.
- You're my wife.
You honestly can't think
you can run Russia
without bloodshed?
- I can.
I'm winning.
- I love that you think that.
ORLO: He's a threat.
I really, really want
to kill him.
- Reason and compassion can win
any argument
better than violence.
- Let's just behead him
like civilized men.
CATHERINE: We must act.
Let us remake Russia,
my friend.
- Everyone expects you
to only last a year.
- I am safe
until the baby is born.
- It must be strange,
a human creature inside you.
Do you ever think,
"What if he has a knife?"
- I never do.
- Hmm.
ELIZABETH: This is a dynasty.
If she loves you,
you'll make more babies
and protect the family line.
You must make her love you.
- Should we have sex?
- I'd rather choke to death
on this tiny chicken.
- I have been trying
to change myself.
- When you are flawless!
- Exactly.
It's time I regain the throne.
- And then you kill her.
- Imprisoned
until Paul is born.
- You're a good dad.
PETER: You're not long
for the throne.
I'm chosen by God.
You were chosen by mail order.
Ponder that.
CATHERINE: I had a busy day
running Russia,
the country
I just took from you.
Go get him!
[gasps]
- Are you kidding?
That could have been me!
She loves me, that is certain.
- You sure?
- I look at you
and go dry like sand.